[Music]
how is the American Catholic party
different than the libertarian party
because I was reading the platform in
the principals and all that did you
think what did you like it I did like it
a lot I mean it's yeah I mean it's
exactly the stuff that I've I've been
talking about and without crit you know
you're not staking out crazy positions
these all seem very it seemed based in
the reason and logic that I try to apply
anything so I like that
yeah but how is that different than the
Libertarian Party
well speaking of reason and logic I
think libertarianism in the end is about
whim worship sort of the thing that's
animating the Trump phenomenon
libertarianism as far as I can see the
most consistent practitioners of
libertarianism don't think that
government has an appropriate place in
society at all they consider a coercive
monopoly that will always be a course of
monopoly irrespective of whether or not
it's constrained by a contract like a
constitution and so they just want to
eliminate it entirely and put force on
the marketplace if the way other you
know goods and services are traded and
capitalism understands the capitalist
party understands that to be a very bad
idea right it forces into marketable
commodity and that it needs to be
deposited in an organization that that
is governed by objective laws and whose
sole purpose is to protect the
individual from criminals and from the
initiation of force yeah so when people
give capitalism [ __ ] when they basically
are like it's just not working and look
what's happening in America or all the
all the Bernie rallies and he talks
about the 1% and even though it's really
the point 1 percent I think that he's
really talking about cuz they talk about
the 1% it sounds like if you make around
400 grand you're in the 1% at 400 you're
not pulling the strings of of
politicians you're living a nice lecture
but but so the real problem the people
having with capitalism now I think is
the crony capitalism that we have right
just the way that bad actors have used
the capitalist system do you think
that's fair to say well I mean yeah and
I wouldn't call it
capitalism I think I think cronyism is a
form of statism it's fascism and and and
linking it with capitalism sort of puts
capitalism in us in a spectrum that it
doesn't deserve to be put in I mean what
we have now and have had for over a
century is a mixed economy where there
is elements of freedom and elements of
controls and the elements of freedom of
course lead to the prosperity that we
like in the elements of control
dislocate the market from the the
measuring tools that it needs in order
to you know give us what we want it
dislocates the market from the price
prices and from the profit and and from
the things that enable you know the
resources and capital to be allocated
properly and causes these kinds of
massive economic problems that we've had
over the last century or so since the
coming of the Federal Reserve so I I
don't I don't like linking businessmen
who have political pull with free-market
people who produce a value that other
people want right so you see that more
as a political problem analytical then a
problem of capitalism itself but that
shows you how these this stuff is also
intertwined right because if you make a
lot of money then you have access to
politicians who can then change laws too
then you rigged the system yep so we're
in like a real a real mess here right
yeah so how do we at this point
understanding that I mean how do we
unpin some of that without burning the
system down because that's what it to me
right now it seems to me that the Bernie
people and the Trump people that they
have one thing in common which is let's
burn down and I would say the system as
screwy as it is and unfair as it is and
it needs to get better but burning it
down I don't think is is the way to go
well I think eventually that is the
solution I think there is no compromise
between statism and Liberty it's one or
the other
and you see over the last 120 some odd
years how the one is slowly taking over
the other because because of the fact
that the the the political right who's
supposed to stand for the free-market
hasn't
because they can't because they've been
compromising the entire time yeah with
statism so in the end the system does
have to go in favor of either one that
protects individual rights or one that
fully endorses the states rights to to
direct the life of the individual so but
but I think it has to be dismantled not
in one fell swoop there's too much
dependence on right right well that's
what I mean that when you're just they
like the idea of burning it down but I
just think come out on the other side we
don't know what will happen so you think
there's a way of sort of incrementally
getting rid of some of this stuff some
of this regulation and it incrementally
came upon us I think that's the way you
have to ease our way out of it but I but
I think it's it's up to the
intelligentsia and the artistic
community to embrace the different
values that in order to make this
palatable to the American people I mean
if you continue thinking that altruism
is is the appropriate moral code then
statism is simply going to be the
political extension of that and if you
believe that you have a right to your
own life and that the pursuit of your
happiness is a moral good then then you
know a different system is is what you
would you would be for and that's going
to take some time to saturate the
culture notions yeah we got a lot of
work in front of them you do this is the
answer so you believe that those those
moral concepts that those really come
from man right there is in a this has
nothing to do with religion or with I
don't know what your personal feelings
on religion atheist but okay you're an
atheist so so that's also interesting
because I've talked you know I talk a
lot about the political side and I talk
a lot about atheism there there's some
connection there what what is that
connection I mean I don't know if you
were gonna tell me you're Christian or
you're believer or whatever I think it's
gonna be irrelevant I think it's been a
disastrous thing that capitalism has
been linked with judeo-christian values
and capitalism has been linked and and
the concept of rights have been linked
to an unprovable and knowable God I mean
to me the concept of right is just means
a freedom of action
and it's observable it's an you can see
in reality why a human being needs to be
free from force okay right you can't
think with a gun pointing it to your
head and you can't act in your own
interests or pursue values or create
values with a gun pointed to your head
hmm so the concept look rights wouldn't
matter if you were on a desert island
property wouldn't matter if you were on
a desert island by yourself it's it's
it's a social moral concept in it and it
comes from our nature it it's it's
founded in and and it comes from our
nature as rational beings and I think
linking it to God makes it unjustifiable
yeah in the in the eyes of any rational
human being out there right and that's
where they've also used government
they've been able to link it to God and
then made government bigger so if you're
on the right like I give so much crap to
my friends on the Left who are
controlling language doing doing all the
things that you just laid out right now
so I'm trying to to bring the left back
a little Center I think but but it's the
people on the right who have used God in
this equation that have expanded
government because as we said before
they are the ones that want to control
who you marry and what you smoke and all
that and that is the reverse of
everything else they're supposed to
believe in agreed and and but the left
is the same thing I remember reading a
quote from Theodore Roosevelt who
started this disaster of progressivism
that he cared about people not property
and I've had discussions with people on
the Left who simply do not understand
that property in the life the pursuit of
your happiness your body and property
are intimately intertwined and you can't
have one without the other so that's why
the left I think
thinks it's okay to to take and
redistribute what you've earned talk
about people in the name of the good
because your property is something
communal it's it goes for something
greater than you I on the other hand as
you're right I also think a lot of it's
just nonsense I think a lot of them
don't practice what they preach they
live for themselves they try to maximize
their own profits I think a lot of them
their own businesses would be happy not
to have you
or do every other which way to not give
their employees $15 an hour
sure I mean I see this with people I
know and how they treat people that
they're you know that are huge lefties
that don't really live up to any of
these principles so that's that virtue
signaling thing like I'm so good I'm so
good look how good I am right but it's
unlivable it's not it's not really a
moral premise that can sustain itself or
sustain life you know you you you and I
don't and I don't think it's an
appropriate moral code to have to have a
standard of value that's outside your
ability to achieve and and to define the
good in such a way that it's impossible
to achieve it or impossible to have a
good life while achieving it or
impossible to have any life while
achieving it right so how do we get the
younger people on board this because
that's the the part we've touched on it
slightly I mean the college stuff right
now we know is completely out of control
every day you know I mean we see
protests you can protest but if you're
silencing people now we have a free
speech problem and I keep saying I'm not
that concerned at the moment that the
government is coming for my free speech
but I am concerned that our our social
contract of letting each other speak
that well that's being shredded right
now so what do we do in terms of getting
some young people on board this well I
think I think these ideas have to start
entering the culture you know and have
to start finding some acceptance in the
universities themselves and that's going
to take a couple of generations I think
in the meantime I think political
movements can sort of be the initiator
to cultural movements you know I think I
think progressivism even though is an
intellectual movement it was sort of
foisted on the American people first I
don't think they they necessarily were
behind the idea that the stage it should
control every aspect of your life you
know in the night early 1900s sort of at
the height of the capitalist movement
and that so for me progressivism came is
as a political movement that sort of
saturated the culture and I'm hoping
that
bringing these capitalist ideas to the
fore and presenting them in a way that
any rational human being could look at
them and say what problem do I have with
this this makes complete sense is a way
of initiating some cultural change right
so that really though is the is the real
damage that these trigger warnings and
safe spaces and all that does right that
now these kids are just simply they
won't even get to hear what you've just
laid out or what some other person might
laid out because they could be offended
by it or it somehow seems racist because
you're not putting everyone on this
chart of oppression Olympics so we have
to crack that and I don't know that we
have generations to do it well I think
also redefining some political terms
will help that as well liberalism had a
long tradition of intellectual
intellectual strength yeah and and it
was it was taken over you know and it's
changed now and I think taking back that
that label so that the political left
isn't able to progress further as a as a
party that's connected to intellectual
values but you know simply disconnect
them from the concept of liberal and and
return liberalism to its you know
rightful place which is anyone who
believes that the individual has a right
to their own life and who adheres to
reason in reality can be a political
liberal and and and just let the left
and the right kind of coalesce and find
their own political yeah and most people
are there I really believe that most
people I was watching Gary Johnson I
think this weekend on CNN and was saying
that he thinks around 40% of the
American electorate if they really
understood this stuff they'd realize
that they pretty much are for smaller
government as a rule that they are for
social liberalism and letting people
live the way they want but we get so
caught up in the craziness and then you
throw in a trump into this situation and
we just never have the intellectual
discussion about it so that's sort of
where where we fall right like we've got
a we've got to keep pushing well I mean
I I don't know if politics has always
been this way
I feel like back in the day that there
was some conceptual component to it now
it's concrete bound emotion driven and
you can't really get beyond bromides and
sound bytes you know that and this is
the one arena where there really should
be deep discussion because we're talking
about social ethics those are concepts
that are just not so easily flushed out
yeah we don't have any of it I mean
really if you think about all I think
about all the debates on both sides I
think there were a couple debates were
on the Democratic side they really had
some interesting substantive stuff when
they were talking about guns for example
I think there were they had some
differences Bernie explained why yeah
he's been more relaxed on guns than
Hillary in a rural state but pretty much
these debates and almost everything we
see in the media is anti-intellectual
right yeah I mean sure when you turn on
cable news do you ever feel smarter
after that that's I mean I watch at this
point I really only watch when I'm doing
cardio and I just put it on I take my
earbuds in and out cuz I can't even
watch ya for that long but I but I
always feel Dumber I always feel I
haven't learned anything and that's so a
lot of this is just media stuff too
yeah and that's visual media too and
visual media is more superficial and it
goes for the bells and whistles and and
you know the the headline grabbers and
the thing that will immediately
emotionally draw you in as opposed to
the more substantive conceptual stuff
that I think you and I want to see right
when we're watching so part of this is
just the nature of how we get news right
we're so used to Twitter who are so used
to vine and snapchat everything is so
short but to get people if if we were to
have a real debate you know every time
there's a debate I'm saying these aren't
debates a debate is where you challenge
someone's ideas directly these are
precision questions that most likely
they've been tipped off to war hand and
that's that's really infuriating to
watch sure everybody's can everybody has
their they're rehearsed responses
nobody's know to be speaking
off-the-cuff or at least off-the-cuff
intelligent you know and and so we have
this sort of canned universe that where
watching unfold more eyes where do you
think capitalism is working better than
it's working right here is there a
country that you look at and you go or a
system somewhere or even a microcosm of
it in America somewhere let you go this
this is how it's supposed to work and
that's what we can use as a little bit
of a path to get there well ironically I
don't think there's any country on the
face of the earth that embraces
capitalism fully but the even more
ironically the countries of Bernie
Sanders talks about are more free than
America they have more capitalist
elements to them than America and you
know they certainly confiscate more of
their citizens wealth and redistribute
it but there are a lot of ways in which
you can say that those countries are not
socialist paradises but mixed economy
with more elements of freedom than even
the United States wait so what's that
what's the freer part so when he's
talking about somebody's really more
like the Scandinavian countries that's
where they're they have incredibly high
tax card behind acts but it easier to
start businesses you know and a much
less certification and licensure stuff
stuff like that that makes you know that
makes capitalism rather difficult here
or the government creates obstacles here
to to making new businesses are not
present there and and so it's not really
an accurate thing for him to point that
out the point those two those countries
of socialist mecca's and since since
they're just embracing free markets and
and a couple of them like Sweden you
know had a free-market revolution in the
in the 19th century that that carried on
into the into the 1960s when the
Socialists took over so capitalism is
such a powerful thing that it can be
dead for decades and decades and decades
in a country and even ideologically dead
and yet still the productivity that was
generated from that from that explosion
of the free markets creates wealth still
even though it's sort of an intellectual
dead letter over there right so where
does the the pure capitalists or where
does the American capitalist party where
would you guys fall out on taxes because
um I guess ultimately because I do
believe in equality because I believe in
real equality I'm pretty
much for a flat tax I would also say
that you could have some level of
progressive tax that would make sense so
that if somebody I'm not talking about
if you make a million dollars you should
be taxed more necessarily but at some
level maybe over twenty million we can
figure out little percentages you know a
quarter you I think there's some
fairness in there and I know that
probably a lot of libertarians would say
no that's not fair at all right I could
do some of that do you follow that line
of thinking at all what's your general
feeling on taxes well first of all I I
think that the graduated tax is is not
really just for the most part a person
who is earning that kind of money has
also created exponentially more wealth
than they're actually taking home so but
a lot of people say they're just hiding
that money they're hiding it but you
would argue that they're they buy in a
big house and they have to have a
gardener and a well I would say that a
Bill Gates takes home 50 billion dollars
he's created two trillion two trillion
dollars of wealth so the fairness of
taxing and you know more because he has
fifty billion dollars sort of loses its
its moral luster when you consider that
he's created exponentially more wealth
that benefits everybody I think I wasn't
totally sold on what I think there's a
there's an argument to add there and I
haven't quite well I just think I think
people forget that a person has that
kind of wealth because they've created
exponentially more wealth so they so
they forget that they have a
misperception that you know all these
people are just sitting there they're
they're shuffling papers around or
they're they're making transactions that
are really not benefiting Evan to
anybody so it's just money accumulating
on money and then nobody benefits for
that which is it's sort of impossible I
think in in the way the economy works
today even if you just set your money in
a savings account somewhere I mean it's
it's going to be benefiting other people
in in innumerable ways but as far as
taxation goes i III support a flat tax
as a sort of intermediary stage to what
I think is ideal and and what I think
has ideal it is a completely voluntary
tax system where
where you pay a very very very small
amount of your income to support the
legitimate functions of government so if
you think about it you know if the
government now functions it what is it
what does it function what does it
function out every year now it's a lot
really huge but the actual the actual
proper functioning of a Nightwatchman
type government that just protects your
rights is really really really
infinitesimally small in comparison so
it would be a very very very small
fractional amount of your income in
comparison to what we have to give today
but did you say voluntary voluntary so
so most people are gonna hear that what
is he talking about who's gonna
volunteer to give the government money
well if you're actually well right now
we have an adversarial system that where
people sense the injustice of having the
fruits of your labor stolen from you and
your values subverted and your dream
subvert it for the sake of other people
even if they don't want a minute they
they sense that that's sort of an unjust
thing but if if you're paying the police
and the courts and the army to protect
you from bad guys it's something that I
think most people can wrap their their
heads around and so what would what
would be those core things so it's
police it's firemen it's roads no no no
I don't even know the roads really
[Music]
firemen we've got a little Atlas
Shrugged here right well I mean look of
course there was a time when you know
the people were responsible for that
themselves or when the burden fell to
the states you know in a more federalist
system but I definitely think that the
the civil civilized society delegates
the use of force to a to a body that is
governed by objective law and so and so
that is the purpose of government is
simply to protect you from bad guys from
fraud and force and invasions and and
stuff like that and and the
infrastructure of the country is more or
less the responsibility of you and I and
and I think it is in our interest to to
build these things it's or to have
somebody build them and to pay them for
that right so that goes to where I
started which is that people think that
the
self-interested is selfish but usually
by being self-interested you actually
are interested in the greater good
because you understand that that helps
you right I mean is it isn't that the
the piece of that right you're gonna go
I'm self-interested but I want roads so
I'm going to help roads be made well you
know I think yeah I mean when I hear
greater good it's a little scary to me
because because pretty much every
authoritarian government on the planet
that's murdered millions upon millions
done it in the name of the greater good
and you have to reduce that greater good
to the individual and there is no
greater good than the individual and
certainly a person pursuing their own
values and exchanging with somebody else
has to have a reputation if they want to
continue to exchange with another person
which means they have to produce and and
and be a benevolent reputable member of
their their community yeah I think
there's no more benevolent community
than one that says I don't expect the
unearned and hopefully you don't as well
we can exchange as equals with each
other we can trade to mutual benefit but
that's how that's and that that is
that's how we maintain a non violent non
aggressive society that's how we avoid
conflict with each other I respect you
as an individual and your property your
life as inviolable as mine so I can't
like I would by virtue of that ethics
alone you know not treat you in a manner
that would hurt you or violate your
cause you pain
[Music]